[Applause]
[Music]
first trailer for the next Avengers plus
we get a title Avengers end game pretty
good title call I think as far as it
goes not that it's like an amazing um
you know title it's kind of generic all
things considered
but given that most of the time when the
Marvel movies have gone in for a
subtitle they've picked one that is a
specific story even if they weren't
adapting that story directly you know
just to give a feel for and then there's
all the speculation you know will they
be how much will they be pulling from
the source that they took the name from
you know they did with Ragnarok Civil
War Winter Soldier infinity war all this
stuff I kind of like that they used one
that maybe there's an end game storyline
somewhere in Marvel but if there is like
it's never stood out it's not it's not a
it's not a thing where you mean they go
oh it's gonna relate to this and I kind
of like that I look I'll be blunt I love
this teaser and now commence all the
comments calling me a Disney shell and a
Marvel fan boy or whatever else but look
I don't know how the movies gonna be I
have no idea how the movies gonna be but
I will tell you this teaser for me is
exactly what I want in a teaser
especially a teaser that is part of a
larger franchise that I'm already
familiar with give me slower moments
give me quiet moments give me character
focus give me a sense of feel and do not
give me plot and that is exactly what I
get from this so again am I saying it's
gonna be the most amazing movie ever no
I can't judge that from the trailer but
I can tell you that this teaser this is
this is what I love when it comes to
teaser style marketing this right here
like I I will watch this again after I
finish this up now that having been said
it is really weird to me that Marvel
really
this so soon after dropping the Captain
Marvel one like I know I know that the
Internet can have you know a short
attention span but this is so close
together it does feel a little bit like
stepping on their own toes and I'm not I
don't know I don't know why you wouldn't
wait just another week so like that
strikes me as odd I'm sure there'll be
conspiracy theories about all that and
I'm not gonna indulge them but just as a
thing that's a little weird to me but
coming back to the teaser itself so I I
love opening with Tony you know yeah the
guy whose movie started this whole thing
I love opening with that I love the eye
I'm not gonna lie I choked up a little
at the sense of hopelessness coming
through his voice in that performance I
thought that was incredibly well
delivered
I just and God I get it like I felt the
lump again when we get to it with the
few images we get of Captain America
he's got a tear and then he you know
he's saying yes this will work cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't I'm like oh my god the walking
embodiment of hope and optimism and
right we'll rent when out in this
universe is he is holding up my threat
he is so close to being broken by what
has gone on like that that's just a
powerful vibe and giving us the
reminders of who we've lost and focusing
sort of on the pain of those left behind
and giving us sort of the quiet moments
of Thanos just strolling through a field
he got exactly what he wanted a couple
of few other things we get we get an
image of of Hawkeye but sort of in his
Ronin thing which has never been my
personal favorite and I that within the
context of the teaser it could very well
work in the movie but within the context
of the teaser that felt the least earned
because it felt the most I guess
overdramatic seems throwing worth whole
thing's overdramatic
just because I think it's because he
wasn't in the previous movie so like
this whole Oh sword Oh
Hawkeye I'm like dude where were you
I'm not going like a whole wait I'm like
where were you so I I think maybe it's
that field that made that probably the
softest moment for me in terms of like
not hitting me as hard as pretty much
everything else did but it was this was
a good teaser and I do like the
insertion of Scott Lang a vamp man at
the end there I like him for a couple of
reasons first of all I like that you
know Captain America's looking at the
images of everyone they lost and Scott
Lang's up there which makes sense
because spoilers Frank man in the wasp
at the end of that movie and the bonus
scene at the end he goes into the
quantum verse and then the people who
were helping him get there and were
gonna help him get out you know hope
Hank and Janet
they all got dusted so that means that
from an outsider's perspective no one
else knew where he was and he just
vanished so it makes sense that they
would lump him together with the with
the dead and I kind of liked that as a
because I saw that I mean I'm like oh
they're gonna be surprised when he shows
up and I kind of like that they pay it
off with him the teaser again because
that doesn't feel like a plot spoiler in
any way but I also like it because it's
a reminder that look for as dour as this
is as serious as this is as broken as
our heroes are right now we can still
have a little fun we can still have some
moments of levity this is not going to
be a funeral of a movie and that like
that was the perfect note to end on and
at this point Marvel has a tendency to
end its trailers whether it's the
teasers or the full trailers you know
following the title on a more comedic
note I mean even Infinity Ward did that
with you know with Thor kind of gone who
the hell are you guys and we see the
Guardians which I mean isn't like so
much a joke but like these this is the
light hearted characters we know are
gonna be there and it kind of does the
same thing here and while it is a little
bit queueing to formula as far as these
trailers being put together as goes for
me it's a formula that
works so yeah I was already really
excited for this movie that I'm not sure
this actually makes me more excited
because anymore that this sort of
reaffirms the excitement that I had
coming out of infinity Wars so I am
pumped and and like I said it I'm now
having a hard time like clinging on to
the memory of the Captain Marvel movie
and I feel like that that was a mistake
you know to lump them together like this
but like taking this thing as a thing on
into itself I love this teaser I think
it's a phenomenal teaser it is a
terrific way to just you'll announce the
movie you know let you know the feel the
tone who's there sort of where are we
but then that's it
like I always dread watching full
trailers cuz I'm like crap how much of
the plot are they gonna get a giveaway I
love teasers love them when they're done
well sometimes they can suck but broad
strokes assuming it doesn't just stink I
love teasers and I love this
so Avengers end game what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff you can do because there's buttons
and there's links including one to my
patreon if you feel thing um being a
little bit supportive in that fashion if
not don't worry other links you can
check out too don't want to click on
them that's fine too because at the end
of the day folks you're the council I
just run the meetings until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]